何か聞きたいことでもございましたら
もう今日の話についてあれやこれやとわからなかったんですからね
何も質問ないかもしれませんけど
もう何でもいいんだから
質問あったら  質問ある方挙手していただければマイク回しますので
時々法句経ではね ものすごい難しい偈もあります
今日はそういう風にもすごい簡単そうに見える
とてつもない難しいという
あえて簡単に見えちゃうんですよ
内容難しくなると  そういうものもありますけどね
はい 何か質問があったら
はい どうぞ マイク回しますので
はい えっと 質問というか
生きることが結構楽でもないし
よくもないし 結構苦しいことの方が多い人生なんですけども
それでもどうしてもまだ生きることに未練
生きるっていうか 未練というか
執着がどうしても抜けられないんですけども
これはどうすれば どうすれば
その生きることに対してというか
この世に対する未練ですね
いろいろお金とか財産とか
あるいは愛する人々とかというものに対する未練がどうしても抜けられないんですけど
これはやっぱどうしようもないんでしょうか
それともそれを それが本性なんです
それを破るのが理性ある人のやることなんでしょうか
ちょっと なんとなく あの質問というよりも
問いかけを投げられたような感じで
どう返せばいいかちょっと迷ってるんですけども
ちょっと質問にならないかもしれませんが
どうすればいいんでしょうか？っていう感じなんですけど
それはね みんなの問題ですからね
例えばね いくら人生が苦しくてもね
楽でもない苦でもないというよりは
もう本当に苦しい人であっても執着するんですね
生きることに 生きていきたいと思っちゃうんですね
それがこの仏教は無知というんですね
無知が理性がないんだから生まれるんですね
そちらには理由がありまして
生きるということは心を回転させることなんですね
心回転させるためには刺激が必要なんです
だから心を回転させたい
ただそれだけ それに刺激が必要です
だから 目に見えるもの
耳に入るものに依存するんです
あまり大さっぷすぎですよ
財産が欲しいやらとかね
家族のことを好きだとか
そんなところじゃないんですよ
家族いたって耳で 目で
体で家族っていうことを知ってるんであってね
微妙に科学的に見た方がいいんですよ
自分に家族がいるんだっていうことは
目で見て知ってるでしょうに
耳で音を聞いて知ってるでしょうに
体で触ったり触れたりして知ってるでしょうに
具体的には そこなくなったら家族がいるかいないか分からなくなるでしょうに
結局 目で見たもの 耳で聞いたものを
体で触ったものに対する心の中に執着が生まれているんです
そこで心の中でまた回転するんですね
家族のことを考えたりする
という感じで これ概念になっちゃうんですね
目の前にいないのに 見ることも触ることもできないのに
別なところにいる時でも家族
家族と思ったりして それは単純な概念の回転なんですね
そういうことで 結局科学的に見ると
眼耳鼻舌身に情報触れて刺激を受ける
それが生きることなんです
刺激が欲しいという強烈な心理学的に言えばね
要求があるんです それが私たちは一般の知識に戻して落としてもらって
別な言葉で家族が欲しいとかね
金が欲しいとかね 高級ブランドの服やらいろんなもの
品物が欲しいとかって言ったりするんですよ
それはあまりにもレベルを落としてから
俗世間のレベルで喋ることであって
心理学的に言えば もう現に鼻失神として刺激が欲しいと
そのところから見ると
刺激なら何でもいいということになるんです
私たちのレベルではカバンなら何でもいいってことじゃないんです
あまりにも頭混乱しているんですね
もうなんとかイタリアのフランスのブランドのカバンでなければとかね
いうふうなことにしますけど
心の状況を見れば どっちででもいいんです
刺激を受けるんです 例えば
あの香港で安く手に入ったと
すっごいブランドのカバンと
自分で調べたところ これはすごいすごいもので
半額よりも以下やと ここで調べてみたら
これも偽物やと って言われたりする
それでオリジナルのブランドのカバンを持ったら自分が気分がいいと思っていたでしょ
せっかく買ったもの オリジナルでもなく偽物であると
そうすると刺激が消えるんですかね
全然消えないんです あ
悔しいんだ 騙されたんだとかね
そういう刺激が生まれるんです
心にはどうでもいいんです
それで生きているんです
生き続けるんです 家族がいるんだって言って舞い上がって刺激で生きている人もいて
子供が殺されたということで
その部屋はそのまま置いておいて
10年でも 15年でも恨みながら生きている人もいるんです
犯人を恨んだり憎んだりして
ずっといるんです 自分の幸福を奪ったと
人間にとってはただ刺激が欲しいだけなんです
で それで刺激が欲しいと怯えることは無知なんです
心理知らないんですよ
刺激っていうのはありすぎなんです
そんな要求しなくても
あの サプライはありすぎなんです
我々はサプライはすごく少ないと
さっさと取らなくちゃと怯えているんです
例えば ほら インターネットでもいろんな商売
店やってますよ あの いろんな品物を
昨日私はちょっと調べて
何か買おう 買おうかなと思ってやめちゃったんですけど
あの 50個しか売れませんと
あと3つ残ってるんだと
ちょっとデザインのいい12GのあのUSBドライブ
もうフラッシュドライブあったんですけど
あれは売れちゃって もう一つありましたけど
デザインちょっと違うんですね
これは嫌っていうことでやめたんですけど
それはあと4個残っていたんですね
なんであの10個4個のあれ
からくりやってますかね
で  6万ね 一番性能のいいパソコンを売っているんだと
6万でこんなこんな機能入ってるならば
まあ結構いいんじゃないかなと思ってアクセスしてみると
あの10台に限るという
ではメーカーはなんでしょうかといったら
もうメーカー Acer
とかエイサーのメーカーで
あいつの連中はいくらでも作って売りまくりたいだけなんですよ
なのになんで10台だけに限っちゃうんですかね
売りたくないんですか？作りたくないんですか？と会社に
あの あの外国の会社ですけど
聞きたいんだけど 外国新聞雑誌ではもうむちゃくちゃ宣伝していますよ
同じAcerが どちらかというとわりかし安いんですから
結構みんな使ってます
日本ではたくさんメーカーがあるんだからね
それほど一般的に使ってないかもしれませんだけど
外国では少量で使っているものなんです
あれが何なのかというと
この偽掛けのサプライが少ないんだそうと
だから飛んで買えということなんです
早い者は勝ちという テレビショッピングも同じなんですね
個数は決まってるんですけど
次の日も同じコマーシャル流れてますけど
今電話してくださいと
次の日また50個持ってくるんです
それがバレるんだから
次の日ではなくて もう2日 3
日飛ばして また同じようなものを出すんですね
その時言い訳もしますよ
あまりにも要求があったんだから
苦労して会社に頼んでお願いして
もう一度皆様に提供することにしましたと
皆様は舐めていますけどもね
むちゃくちゃ馬鹿にされてますけどね
それでも胸を張ってるんだからね
貶してますよ お客さんに対する全然愛情も何もないんです
あの連中どうせ馬鹿どもたちだからね
こう言えば買っちゃいますよと
それで我々は儲かるんだよという理屈なんです
それであのサプライとデマンドで考えてみれば
サプライはこれ日本語の単語あると思いますよ
え？ 供給  高級？ 供給  供給
デマンドは？ 需要  え？需要
それで供給が少なくなると
需要が大きいんだったら必死で買わなくちゃいけなくなるんですよ
心は錯覚していますよ
この刺激の供給が少ないんだと
だから我々は必死で刺激刺激探してるんですよ
いい音楽ないのか 面白い映画ないのかとか
美味しい食べ物ないのかとかね
今度の休み どこ行こうかなとかね
頭痛めて考えて そんなことなくても刺激があるんですよ
もし休みにどこかに旅に出たら
それは刺激でしょうね
休みはどこかに行こうかと
いくつか場所が選んで決めて電話したんだけど
満員満員だと断られたっちゃって
それで 1箇所空いてますけど
自分持ってるお金よりは 3倍かかるんだと
普通旅館どこかで泊まりたいんですけど
それは全部満員で 行くだけは空いてますけど 10
万円やと これはもうできないんだからね
そうすると家でいるんですね
どこにも行かないで 悔しいとかね
去年あれ 去年1年ぐらい先に予約した方が良かったんだとかね
どうせ金がないんだからね
もう人間ってダメですねもう
あれやこれやと 俺結構刺激ですよ
だからもしもし供給が無制限にあるならば
需要ってどうなるべきですかね
需要のことが減るはず
ゼロになるはずなんです
我々は空気吸わなくちゃと一度も思ったことないでしょうね
ご飯食べなくちゃってことを思うんだけど
どこで食べ食べましょうかとかね
ああ 空気吸わなくちゃ
どこら辺の空気 それない
なぜならばいくらでもあるんだから
そちらには欲も何もないんです
もし人が心の刺激が無料に無制限にあるとしたならば
すぐ要求が消えちゃうんです
何歳でも生きていきたいってことはなくなっちゃう
そんなことじゃなくて
これやばいと そういうことで理解しないと
この生きていきたいという欲が消えませんね
だから なんとなく分かっただけではもう足りませんね
だから この生きることには執着あるっていうことは
誰にでもそういう問題はあります
ただ 無知から出てくるんです
そんなに必死になっているのは
供給が少ないと思ってるんだからなんです
だから戦うんですよ 戦争もするんです
人殺しもするんです 刺激のために
金のために 勘違いなんです
金がたくさんなったら幸福で生きていられるんだと
なくても生きてられるのに
なかったらないことの刺激で生きてるんですよ
あれもない これもないと
もう刺激なんです 欲しい欲しいと思うことも刺激なんです
いくらでも刺激があるんです
金がないな 金がないなと思っちゃうと
それで頭が回転するんです
金が欲しい 金が欲しい
また頭が回転するんです
じゃあ金が入ったら金が入ったか
それでまたどうやっても心は回転するんですよ
それで心はあの自家発生で無料に刺激作るんです
心は怯えていて 刺激がなかったら困ると
だったら自給自足でやるんだと
自給自足ではないんです
自給も不足で自給いくらでもあるんです
それで不安なんです だから心だけでいくらでも刺激作るんです
この心が自分で自家発生で刺激作るんだからなんですよ
輪廻するのは でないと輪廻がないんです
だから山火事みたいなもんですよ
この欲求 もう無制限に欲求を持つことが
また誤解ですよ だから欲求は無制限にあるって思っている
誤解です ないんです じゃあ供給がありすぎ
それだけなんで 事実は
[背景音楽]本当は欲求はゼロになるはずなんです
空気吸いたいとあまり思ってないぐらいゼロになるはずなんです
空気は吸ってますけど
でも誰も空気を吸いたい吸いたい
どうしましょうかと困ったことは一度もないんです
ということで 理性があればそこら辺はわかります
そういうところにはやっぱり知識というか知恵がね
やっぱり修行によって知恵を高くすると見えてくるんですね
普通に考えても 現に身心に即した考えだから
五感に囲まれた思考だから
生きる欲が消えません
世間の常識で考えても
ということになります
だから 質問には答えは知恵を開発するべきということで
そう思われることが やっぱりそれも無知の仕業であると
私たちは騙されているんですから
そのそれの仕業なんですね
やっぱりいくらなんでも
いくら言っても やっぱり生きることには執着は捨てられ捨てがたいということはね
騙されているということなんです
無知にやられているということなんです
で 知恵を開発するべきだと
欲は置いておいて 放っておいて
そのまま 生きることに対する欲はもう別に何もする必要ないんで
そのまま置いておくんです
置いておいて知恵を開発してみるんです
そうすると 自分が大事な宝物として置いといたものに価値があるかないか分かります
はい まあそれぐらいなんですけど
答えがならないかもしれません
だけど 難しいポイントですからね
はい それでは終了します
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
拝礼の後に 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々に 先祖 祖父母 両親
親族 恩師をはじめとし
一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に生かせますように
そして 苦悩が減らされますように
サッビートゥーイワジャンツーサンバローゴーウィナッサトーマーテーバワットワンテラーヨースケデーガーヤコーバワバウトゥサッバマンガランラッカントゥサン
バデーワタサンバブンダヌバーウェナサンバダンマヌバーウェナサッバサンガヌバーウェナサダー スッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリスーニッチャンワッダパチャ
イノーチャッターローダンマワッダンティアユアンノースカンバラン
サーダルサーリプッタサーリプッタ
では どうもありがとうございます